we are seeing an increasingly isolated
and desperate failed former president
Donald Trump descend into a new form of
Madness we heard in an interview
yesterday with his official spokesperson
Liz Harrington that at this point Donald
Trump believes all of his phones are
quote tapped and he is operating as if
that is the case we are going to look at
this clip and understand that it sort of
starts I didn't cut this clip it starts
in this way but what Liz Harrington is
talking about is he just believes that
all of the phones are tapped let's
listen to it and then discuss he's
probably had every phone call ever and
he just assumes so right he assumes
that's the case that's people are
listening in but this man has been spied
on he's been looked at and they have
nothing they've never had anything
because he is so clean I mean he's not
that's why they had such a problem with
him and that's why they still to this
day have such a problem with him because
they're used to being able to have some
sort of Leverage over everybody in
Washington it doesn't matter who they
are there's going to be something
they'll find it they'll use it against
you they can't do that against President
Donald J Trump that's why they have to
make it up however
even though there's nothing
judges signed off on search warrants
grand juries have been impaneled
multiple criminal investigations but
they have less on Trump than on any
other president he's an open book and
that's what they they must be so
frustrated because I was reading this
this sham New York Times article right
about Jack Smith the war prosecutor
right they try to make it so serious
like oh this is the type of guy they
need to come after president Trump and
he's hired the same like cast of
characters who've gone after Roger Stone
have gone after Steve Bannon these
left-wing hacks they must be so
frustrated because they've spent their
lives on this and yet they still have
really nothing yeah they really have
nothing can anybody prove all of Trump's
phones aren't tapped now let's talk
about this in parts
if Trump's phones are tapped so the
first thing is let's imagine that that's
true let's imagine Trump assumes
correctly that the phones are tapped
even though there's no actually there's
no actual evidence to suggest that that
we're aware of if your phones are tapped
you should be really worried because you
can't just tap people's phones with
willy-nilly law enforcement agencies
need to get a warrant to tap someone's
phone by presenting evidence of probable
cause to a judge and that involves
filing a written application with the
court
justifying the reasons for why you want
to do the phone surveillance and if the
judge determines that the evidence
justifies a wiretap they will issue a
court order authorizing a wiretap so the
idea of trump as squeaky clean
but they've tapped everything
really doesn't make sense because
there's at least the existence of
probable cause that you're not squeaky
clean if your phone is getting tapped at
all going further the idea of trump is
squeaky clean in general is silly
multiple criminal investigations grand
juries subpoenas multiple
um uh impeachments going all the way
back to the Mueller probe that was not
able to clear Donald Trump of
obstruction on and on and on and on and
on but the most interesting part of this
goes back to what we talked about at the
beginning of the show
the right is obsessed with saying the
left is all about saying that they are
victims making themselves into victims
false claims of victimhood and on and on
and on
and yet all the right can do
increasingly is say that they are the
victims and look at all of the things
that Donald Trump has claimed to be the
victim of including through his
spokesperson Liz Harrington a victim of
the Russia hoax a victim of impeachment
number one a victim of impeachment
number two a victim of Judges that won't
let him just do whatever the hell he
wants when it comes to policy treat it
unfairly when it came to adjudicating
the 2020 election it was stolen from him
he was victimized there he was
re-victimized by 63 Court decisions
found against him because those were
also politically biased his family has
been victimized even though the reason
this family is being made fun of is Don
and Eric particularly are just pathetic
jokes in terms of the public statements
that they but he's the greatest victim
they know no bottom to this and it's
going to continue being a theme in the
2024 campaign and if he ends up dropping
out before the primaries which is
increasingly a topic of discussion it
will be because he's the victim of
something it's not going to be hey you
know what the uh electorate decided
they're going a different direction they
don't want me and I respect that what
Trump would never say that it will be
the fake news media conspiring with
rhinos and the Republican establishment
and the judicial system which has been
weaponized they all made me a victim
and they pushed me out of the campaign
or whatever that's the way it's going to
be as Trump descends further into
madness I like wine but I know very
little about it and I am completely
clueless when I go to a wine shop I just
don't know what I'm looking for I don't
know what I'm looking at I couldn't tell
you anything about varietals or if
there's hints of Persimmon or any of it
and so if you're like me wishing you had
a seasoned expert by your side when
you're choosing wine crunchy red fruit
is the answer crunchy red fruit delivers
Choice handcrafted small production
wines right to your door every bottle is
hand-picked by owner and master
sommelier Jackson rohrbaugh in Seattle
and comes with food pairing suggestions
we've been chatting with Jackson his
curating puts an emphasis on organic low
intervention wines wines without
artificial yeasts or chemicals crunchy
red fruit sources from small scale
sustainable Vineyards and only wines
that are true to their location and
grape crunchy red fruits bi-monthly wine
club is called the circle every two
months you'll get three or six bottles
to enjoy with videos to help you
appreciate what you're drinking go to
crunchyredfruit.com use the code Pacman
for twenty dollars off a single purchase
or if you join their bi-monthly wine
club send a message to circle
crunchyredfruit.com after you sign up
and they'll take twenty dollars off your
first shipment the link is down below